Khloe Kardashian's son's name seemingly
revealed I've learned from experience it
keeps things close to your heart I don't
know things a little private is all
mystery is good well looks like cat's
out of the bag after Chloe shared this
pic on Instagram holding her nine month
old whom she shares with ex Tristan
Thompson but it's this comment from her
best friend Malika hack that has fans
speculating if she spilled the tea
Malika proudly shares goatee it's not
crazy it's not confirmed if Tate's the
official name of Coco's little one or
just a cute nickname but with the
reality star keeping Malika's comment up
Chloe's only adding fire to the rumor
mill he's he's named but I haven't
announced it you haven't announced it I
haven't announced it yet at first I
really did not know what I was going to
name him I wanted to meet him and feel
him out a little bit and so at first he
didn't and have a name last month Chloe
stopped by the Jennifer Hudson show and
dropped some details behind naming her
son and why she's kept it under wraps
this long I've been waiting for the
premiere of our show and I didn't know
it was going to be this far out so now
I'm just like if my daughter outs me I'm
screwed Well turns out her and Tristan's
first child true wasn't the one she had
to worry about letting it slip genuinely
I cannot believe that while fans will
have to wait until the Kardashians
returns this Thursday to find out if
Chloe actually named her sons Tate she
made this confession in April will his
name start with the T baby I think
everyone we're guessing right I think it
will start with the team it will yeah
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign